And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
Don't we try to answer your questions?
Goodbye, we, we, we, we.
So, we'll leave you.
So, we're gonna be if I don't know the answer.
Okay, let's get started.
Not being able to speed up.
So, if you have questions to chat in,
that was the time to start.
Well, this is gonna be a shoulder call.
Remember to look in what's new,
ever to go to our new video site,
where you'll see all sorts of videos
that were pulled off of YouTube
as their medical disinformation.
Remember, you can make appointments.
When you do hit this appointment,
making schedule, thank you, the option,
schedule a Zoom appointment versus a own appointment.
Why would somebody do a Zoom appointment
versus a phone appointment?
Not to see my pretty face,
because the A, it's not pretty at B,
I don't show that face,
because I'm looking at stuff on your,
trying to type it on file when I'm doing the appointment.
But it's to share my screen.
So, if you're gonna, you wanna go over a lab,
it's best to make a Zoom appointment
because then I can, you know, share my screen
and I can say, see this with that cursor.
It's not easier to go over your lab.
Instead of saying, okay, go to page two,
see this with the upper left-hand cursor,
see what it says here, it's not easier to do it over Zoom.
So, if you wanna make an appointment,
go over your labs, just go to the self-schedule.
When you click on the self-schedule button,
you'll have the opportunity to make
a appointment over Zoom or appointment over.
But it's to go over lab, just do hit over Zoom.
Okay, first question.
I am ready to write programs.
So, we had a lot of people jump on here just lately
before I announced the first one,
we have a lot of questions chatted in or zoomed in
or questions asked prior to the Zoom call.
So, if you have a question, make sure you start
and type in your chat question
so that we can get to it.
Back to the question.
I have been ready.
Write programs lately to help you with allergies
and even briefly to help with a lost steam.
This may be curious, especially in relationship to the allergies,
is the right just managing the symptoms
or is it helping to underline disease, disease or imbalance?
In other words, will the right just manage symptoms
or will it fix what's wrong?
Good question.
So, what's the mechanism of action
for the right frequencies and what frequencies you're ready?
So, I've long said the mechanism action
that I believe the right does for cancer
is it stimulates the cancer cell so that the immune system
will take another look at it and create more T cells
and natural killer cells to kill the cancer.
Your ever cancer is your own cells
so normally your immune system shouldn't attack your own cells.
So, when you hit it with the right,
you're causing it to vibrate, you're causing it
to look differently than other cells,
you're causing your immune system to see it
as an enemy into attack it.
Well, how does that work with other things?
Well, you're ready the right for your liver function,
let's say, how is that work?
Are you killing the liver?
Well, no.
Well, you're ready the right at the liver frequencies,
you're trying to bring back the natural frequency of the,
so when the liver isn't functioning correctly
or what a tissue isn't functioning correctly,
it may be a different frequency.
So, if you could get it to vibrate back
on a normal frequency, you could bring back
normal tissue residents and you could help that tissue heal.
Well, how's it working with allergies?
What's the mechanism of action with allergies?
Well, the mechanism of action with allergies
is you're trying to stimulate a T-reg function.
So, there's different T cells in your body,
there's natural killer cells, there's T cells
that are helping kill cancer, there's macrophages,
there's dendritic cells that then will form into other cells,
and then there's what are called T-reg cells.
So, as far as roles understanding of the immune system,
you have a TH-1 response or an immediate immune response
that kills patients.
You have a TH-2 response or a B cell response that makes antibodies.
You have a B cell response that makes antibodies.
So, the purpose of an immune response to, let's say, a pathogen
is that you fire this immediate cell response
to be able to kill that pathogen.
That's what's taking place in an allergic reaction
or a hyperhistamine reaction.
You're getting this hyper- TH-1 cytokines,
cytokines are different chemicals in an immune response.
You're getting this hyper- TH-1 cytokine response
so it's spilling out these inflammatory cytokines
to stimulate an immune attack on whatever's there.
The problem is whatever is there isn't an immune organism,
let's say in the case of Holland,
then there's nothing to kill,
and you could end up getting this hyperhistamine response.
You couple that with a person having defects in their H-N-M-T gene,
which are the genes that make the D-A-O enzyme,
which breaks down histamine in the tissue.
So, you don't get a lot of tissue breakdown of histamine.
You could end up with excessive histamine response in the tissue,
AKA allergies.
So, a person who has allergy, stifles, coles,
allergic response in the skin, itchy skin,
all this because of, let's say, an environmental allergen,
let's say a, you know, pollen response,
that's the whole cycle that's taking place.
You also have, so you have,
that's the TH-1 response that's taking place.
You don't even want to fire a TH-2 response
because a TH-2 response would be responsible for making antibodies.
So, in a normal, healthy immune response,
let's say you get a bacterial infection.
Your child comes home from school with strep.
You pick up the strep fire, the strep bacteria.
Now, it starts activated in your body and replicated your body.
It stimulates a TH-1 response.
You fire these, the cytokine response to attract T cells,
macrophages, natural killer cells to that site.
You get this antigen pairing response.
It ties to the antigen, the bacteria,
and those T cells kill that bacteria.
Now, let's say it's a really, really bad bacteria.
And you get really sick and you don't feel good.
You get a fever.
The fever is this hyperinflammatory response.
And you have to take off the next day at work.
And you're in the TH-1 response.
It's not stealthful enough to kill that bacteria.
Then it now suppresses and you stimulate the TH-2 side
of the immune system, the B cells.
The B cells go in, find that which you are firing
and TH-1 response against, in this case, the strep.
And you now make antibodies against strep.
That's a good thing.
That's why you don't want to, oh, I don't feel good.
I have a fever.
I'm going to take Tylenol.
I'm going to take just a drug all the time
when you have a bacterial infection.
Sometimes it's good for it to go its course.
So you fire a TH-1 response, TH-2 response,
because that's how you build your immune system.
When you have that TH-2 response,
you could now create antibodies against strep.
So next time when you get strep,
when your child comes home six months from now
from school brings home strep, you don't get sick.
Why?
Because you have a stronger immune system.
How is that defined?
You define a stronger immune system by that
which you have encirculated antibodies against.
I have circulated antibodies against strep.
I have circulated antibodies against this step
that I want to take.
So the more things you have circulated antibodies against,
that is pathogens.
You have circulated antibodies against.
The stronger your immune system is going to be,
AKA, meaning that every time you're exposed to that
or a very similar pathogen, that antibody takes it.
So you're even a mild TH-1 response
that doesn't elicit a fever will kill it quite easily
because it's easy to find.
Think of that antibody as fluorescent tape
that it goes and tags that pathogen.
Okay, too much information?
Well, there's another piece.
There's what's called your T-reg cells,
your T regulatory cells.
So those T-reg cells help balance this.
So you don't get this hyper TH-1 response
or this hyper TH-2 response that could create antibodies
to things that you don't want to to,
like, self-tissue and then causing an autoimmune disease.
So T-reg cells are important.
So that's what I think the allergy frequencies
in the RIF are doing is stimulating a T-reg response.
What are some nutritional things that help
stimulate T-reg responses with allergies?
Might have a D.
Might have a D is a wonderful T-regulator substance.
Bidicinal mushrooms are great T-reg stimulator substance.
That's why a lot of them so much is you could use medicinal mushrooms
to help kill pathogens in people that have an autoimmune disease
because it's not going to be a hyper TH-1 response
staying like a vitamin C well,
but it's going to help stimulate T-reg cells.
Also, understand that immune response.
If you have allergies, you shouldn't be using things
that will just directly stimulate a TH-1 response
like vitamin C and things like that,
that will like, like, echinacea.
And I know a lot of people are taking those things
for their cancer, but if you're experiencing hyper allergic responses
to things that's good to back off
on those for a period of time.
So it calms that TH-1 response down so it helps you
can help get rid of those cytokines.
And when you talk about, OK, I talked about allergies
as far as environmental allergies,
but the exact same thing is taking place
when you get a B-stig or a waspsim sting.
So exact same thing taking place.
How can you know that you don't have H-pylori?
Should I go through treatment protocol just to be sure?
So first of all, go back to the website.
Look at the videos and information I have on H-pylori
and the importance of H-Cl in your stomach
to prevent H-pylori and to even help kill H-pylori
and the things that you could do to help kill H-pylori.
Should you test for H-pylori?
Well, you can.
There is the urea-breath test for H-pylori.
It's a thing that you breed into.
It's a kit that you can buy on a Rupa store.
But it will only test positive if they have H-pylori
and current H-pylori infection in your stomach.
There is a blood test for H-pylori,
but typically the ones that are on the market are IgG blood tests.
So it will only test for cast exposure of H-pylori.
It's not a test for current exposure of H-pylori.
There is a H-pylori stool sample test
that's in the parasite.
It's in the Genova stool parasitology.
And I think it's in the mosaic parasitology lab.
And that test for H-pylori,
that's probably the more accurate one.
But remember, that's only gonna test for what's in the stool.
Whenever H-pylori can start in the stomach
and cause stomach ulcers, could cause stomach cancer.
But it doesn't always just stay in the stomach.
It can get into the intestines.
It could go systemic in your tissues.
It is the cause of rosacea.
It's a cause of a lot of skin rashes.
It is the top four causes of endothelial disease,
heart problems.
So it could be systemic and it most commonly is.
So I typically don't test for H-pylori.
Don't even recommend testing for H-pylori.
You really could diagnose H-pylori
certainly through conhesiology,
but certainly just through looking at your symptoms,
your symptomology.
And again, I said multiple times
that I personally take burburied
on a very regular basis because of H-pylori.
Again, H-pylori.
You look a factor of H-pylori.
It's a bacteria that's the number one
to tell systemic bacterial worldwide.
So it's not a matter whether you have H-pylori or not,
it's whether it's active and causing issues with you.
So this is the reason why you'd want to be a digestive enzymes
and H-Cl products to help prevent H-pylori infection.
So to answer your question,
should you just go through a treatment protocol?
Again, I take clear, pair of clear,
and I take burburied on a very regular basis
just because it's everywhere.
And just because you cleared it up,
doesn't mean you're not gonna get it again next month.
So you're just exposed to it all the time.
Again, hence the importance of H-Cl.
I mean, your proper pH and your stomach
is to help digest your food, right?
But secondary and maybe even a primary reason
is to keep proper pH in your stomach.
That's very acidic is to prevent pathologies.
You're preventing a pathological infection of bacteria,
H-pylori, just one of them.
So any food for infectious organisms, including parasites,
should be killed by pH of 1.5 to 2.5 in your stomach.
So when you've alkalized your stomach,
drinking alcohol and water, or just a poor American diet,
so your pridele cells, your stomach,
they're not producing enough H-Cl.
Then you increase the pH of your stomach,
even to 3.5, you are, you are setting yourself up
for parasites and H-pylori and other passages.
Other food-borne bacteria.
Okay, next question.
In researching IgG food sensitivity tests,
I was surprised to see a lot of medical people,
including the American Academy of Technology,
and asthma and immunology,
stating that there's not enough respectable research
supporting the increased IgG levels that equal sensitivity.
One site suggested studies showing that IgG levels
actually increases allergy sensitivity as a result,
and that IgG levels only indicate exposure
to a substance, not sensitivity to it.
How do these criticisms of IgG panels
better resolve in your mind,
so that you are recommending Cyrex testing?
So Cyrex is a lab that I recommend for food sensitivity testing
and antibody testing to self-tissues,
and to diagnose food sensitivities
and self-antibodies, that means you have
a lot more of your disease.
So first of all, you, I don't give a lot of faith
to any of these American Academy of anything,
because they're all governed by money.
So, but there are tests,
there are possibly studies that show these kind of things.
The reason why I like Cyrex testing is a test for IgG,
IgM and IgA antibodies, not just IgG,
also a test for cooked and raw foods.
Also, I have on the autoimmune course,
I think it's module one or two more details
in what Cyrex tests for.
The other cytotoxic testing for food allergies
that is on the market is what is called MRT testing,
mediator release testing.
What is the Alcat test?
That's probably the most positive.
That's an antigen leukocyte antibody test.
It was called an L-L-R-A test and leukocyte response test.
All of these basically measure non-specific cell size changes.
Actually, most of these tests are banding in some states
because they're highly unreliable.
And you can literally run a person, a lab on a person,
and then send it in, you'll take blood samples
and send it in two different times
and you can get two different results.
So, it's very poor reproducibility.
I antibody testing isn't perfect, though, I will say.
And I don't think like I've said maybe a thousand times
that there is no perfect test.
There's all sorts of reasons a person can end up with antibodies
to different foods and those antibodies can dissipate over time.
So, you could run an antibody test on yourself
and you change your diet in a month later,
you run another antibody test and it can change.
Some for the good, meaning antibodies could go down
and some for the bad, meaning some antibodies could go up.
When you run an antibody test like a Cyrex,
let's say array 10, which tests for a hundred different foods,
cooked in raw, different foods, groups,
different foods, glues, different foods.
Substances that would be found in foods
that could cause reactions to your gut
and you have a lot of reactions to different foods.
The treatment plan is not to simply remove those foods.
The treatment plan is to feel the gut.
So, sometimes when you see antibodies to different foods,
it's really a sign that boy, I really need to increase
by digestive enzymes with my foods.
I'm developing antibodies to XYZ food
because it's not digested well.
For instance, if you have a lot in the nuts category,
if you have a lot of antibodies to the different nuts,
that's difficult to digest.
And if you've got a lot of antibodies
so that gives you a clinical plural
that I probably am deficient in digestive enzymes,
at least when I'm eating nuts, that is my issue.
So if I just started that,
those antibodies would go away at a retest.
So it's not a just a matter of boy,
I have to eliminate these 20 foods completely
though I do suggest you do cut back or eliminate those,
especially the ones that are in the red,
positive on a Cyrex panel.
To calm down the gut,
you gotta work at the same time to heal the gut.
So whenever you have antibodies to food,
that's an abnormal response,
meaning you should never develop antibodies to food.
So why does a person develop antibodies to food?
Well, primarily it's because you have a damaged gut border.
The cells of the gut, the epithelial cells of the gut,
should be close together.
Those are called tight junctions,
where they come in contact,
the cells come in contact with one another.
And that tight junction can be damaged usually because
of your exposed to chemicals
and drugs, antibiotics, glyphosate is a major player in that.
Anything that gets in your gut,
that's gonna cause an inflammatory response
because it's not supposed to be there
because it's a poison,
can damage the epithelial cells,
can weaken the tight junctions.
It's an enzyme bond that holds those together.
Those can break down.
Those tight junctions can spread apart.
And then foods get across the gut wall
that never should have got across the gut wall.
What do you mean?
Well, when you eat a,
let's say I'm gonna eat a liba bean, okay?
That's protein, it's got fiber in it,
other macrodutrients,
but macrodutrients are broken down
and the microdutrients.
So a protein is a long chain of amino acids.
So an amino acid is one substance
and they're chained together, bonded together.
So think of a protein as a pearl necklace
of an amino acids.
Well, you don't absorb the entire pearl necklace
of an amino acids if you did,
you really got a really unhealthy gut
because you have to be quite widespread
if that tight junction for that
to get across the gut membrane.
If you did,
then you would actually develop antibodies
against that protein in your bloodstream
because what, remember,
I explained what the immune system does.
You're at this TH1 response.
It's trying to kill things
that aren't supposed to be their pathogens.
If I can't kill it,
you'll fire a TH2 response, a B cell response.
What's the purpose of that is to make antibodies
against that pathogen.
Well, if there's things in the bloodstream like proteins
that are a bean protein
that never should have been there in the first place
because it should have got broken down
that giant pearl necklace should have
had snipped up down to the maximum
of two little protein,
two little pearl beads that's called a dipeptide.
And most of the time down to a single peptide,
we needed a single amino acid.
Then it could cross the blood through natural beads,
got through a broken blood,
blood got barrier,
but naturally absorbed into the bloodstream
through the got through proper channels.
And then your body takes those amino acids
and in the cells, intercellurally,
you create new proteins
that your body needs to create.
So you take proteins from foods, a livaby.
You snip it down by the use of enzymes
in the gut, snip down to either dipeptides
or a single amino acid.
Then that naturally crosses the gut border into the bloodstream
and goes into the cells
and then your cells turn it into whatever protein.
AKA enzyme is needed to do cellular function
to build tissue, to build muscle,
to do all these different things
that you need proteins to do.
One of them to stimulate a good T cell
immune response for you to kill cancer cells.
Problem is, if you have damaged gut border,
then things are getting across the gut border
in larger forms than should ever have gotten through
in other peptides,
meaning proteins that are broken down into 15 chain peptides,
22 chain peptides, 28 chain peptides,
getting across the gut border,
then your immune system is going,
what in the world is that?
Let's kill it.
Well, can you kill a peptide of a protein?
No, stop living.
So then you fire a B cell response,
you create antibodies against that thing.
What is the antibody going to do?
It's just tagging it.
So every time now that antibody is circulating
into your bloodstream,
every time that antibody is eliciting a response
to an antigen,
it's going to fire in immune response,
it's going to fire in this inflammatory response
and you think it's systemic inflammation.
Worse, those antibodies are also screened
into the lumen of the gut
so that when that peptide now you eat a lymabine
now you fire in immune response
against the peptides in the gut,
even if you are trying to break it down healthfully.
You're firing this immune response in your gut
and you're causing an inflammatory response in the gut
which is this huge negative cycle.
You got more inflammation in the gut,
contaminates the gut,
lighting even more
and this whole negative cycle
creates more problems.
So what do you do?
Well, you do things to heal the gut.
Well, how do you do that?
When you're trying to heal the gut,
you start from the top down.
You make sure you're chewing your food,
you make sure you have proper saliva
because saliva, you have enzymes in saliva, the talent
and enzymes to break down primarily carbohydrates
goes down into your stomach, what does your stomach need?
Deeds HCL, you don't have enzymes in your stomach
primarily, it's mainly hydrochloric acid
to break down proteins,
carbohydrates, advance, mainly proteins.
If you don't have proper HCL production,
you're going to cause just a cascade of problems.
Food's going to go into your small intestine
very partially digested.
It's going to put so much stress on your pancreas.
A lot of theories that that is a major cause
of pancreatic cancer increase over the last few decades.
It goes into their improperly digested,
put so much stress on your pancreas.
Once your pancreas do two things,
makes insulin for your blood,
but also makes digestive enzymes
that's created through the common viral duct
into the duodenum to break down your food in your gut.
It's hyper stress, totally breaking it down partway.
You already have a damaged gut,
so things are crossing as peptides
not as dipeptides or single amino acids
and all that cascade that I just got done
talking about happens.
And now you're about your strength.
So how do you heal it?
From the top down, you're going to make sure you have HCL,
proper digestive enzymes, proper digestive enzymes,
proper digestive enzymes.
I'll break that down.
You can heal your gut through other nutrients
that I listed that course about healing.
You've got different things.
The glycerine, the licorice,
okra, that's where we, with cancer patients,
we don't want to use glutamine.
But glutamine can be helpful to help heal your gut.
There's a bunch of different things in our product,
clear GI that could help heal the gut, slippery L,
other things that could be really gut-feeling products.
A lot of things.
So how do you test for any sense?
How do you test for it?
You do antibody testing.
So you want to get a good test,
the test, not just IgG, but IgM and IgA.
Well, the SiRX-10 test for IgG and IgA,
the SiRX-2 test for IgG, IgM and IgA.
So you're testing for these things
as best as you possibly can.
What if I don't want to do the test?
What if I don't have money to do the test?
Well, then just start eliminating things in your diet,
try to have a rotational diet,
try to clean up your body,
try to decrease the inflammation.
Do the other steps that you could do.
We have patients that I can't afford to do
with all this testing.
That's okay.
Just start doing the things that you can do.
Not everybody can do the testing.
Just do what you can do.
But still, by far, SiRX-Labs is the best tested for this.
Just by opinion.
Next question.
Uncentered in two weeks of Morganella.
My stools became brown instead of tan
and are slightly more forward.
I think this person was taking antibiotics for this.
However, in addition to my bloated belly,
I began retaining fluid.
It went from 112 pounds to 134 pounds now.
Parsley is not helped.
I had two doses of over-the-counter diuretic,
diurex, but no relief.
What is this from and what can I do?
Well, I wish I could just tell you right off the top
of my head, but I am not that smart.
All sorts of things, I mean, different things
could be going on with the bloating.
First thing you think of with bloating,
honestly, is smaller testable bacterial overgrowth.
So that's a possibility,
even if you are taking it antibiotic.
So I would suggest number one,
if you're taking any fiber or eating a lot of fiber
or fiber rich foods or starches
or sugars, try to eliminate that from your diet
right off the bat.
Make sure you're taking HCL.
Make sure you're taking digestive enzymes
to help calm that down.
The other thing I can really help with this is buteric acid.
So like our tributarate,
there's a lot of buteric acids under the market now.
Those would be good to use.
I would even suggest some glutamine
for a short period of time to calm this down.
Again, doing another stool sample test,
that's always good to test, right?
See if there's anything else going on.
If there's other pathogens, anything else going on,
that would be another thing to look at.
But you know, with this information,
you were just, we don't have enough data really
to know without doing some tests.
Also with SIBO, you can't rule out the issue with issues
with the brain gut access.
So very common with people with chronic gut issues,
it's a vagal nerve problem.
So remember, the vagus nerve,
cranial nerve tend comes out of the membrane.
Those down with the spine, it, it,
it innervates the intestinal tract.
And it, it is responsible for the autonomic function
of the intestinal tract.
So when you have a gut rate access,
a type of, type of activation and decrease activation
of the vagal nerve, it can,
it can result in a decrease in motility,
which can lead to SIBO type things as well.
How do you stimulate the vagal nerve?
Go back to our website and look up parasympathetic sympathetic,
and you'll see a whole bunch of parasympathetic stimulating things.
You also see a downloadable PDF chart.
This is also on the, on the cancer course and stuff as well,
how to call the sympathetic.
So remember, autonomic nervous system,
you got the parasympathetics and the sympathetic.
So you have to have that imbalance.
Usually in these cases, it's a hypersympathetic response
because of the imbalance is from a hypovengal response.
The vagus nerve is the parasympathetic response.
So stimulating the vagus nerve.
Look at that, download those charts,
start doing as many of those exercises as possible.
As silly as they seem from a functional neurology perspective,
they can do real well.
Hello, coffee enemas, number one trend for this.
Again, show coffee enemas, number one trend
for vagal nerve stimulation.
Do that as well.
Okay, other questions in here.
Well, you guys are a little bit telling.
Are you able to comment on how an astrosol works
versus to moxifid and the side effects?
I was told by the doctor that an astrosol
is superior to to moxifid.
Same mechanism of action, less side effects.
Well, no, I don't have an answer for that
because I don't have a big enough test subject group,
I guess you could say.
So if your oncologist is saying,
he's seen 100 cancer patients a week,
putting them on these things,
and if he's saying that, I don't know,
I will tend to trust them if somebody's telling you
that has that test group,
that he has done this here, she has done this on,
I would tend to default to their answer on that.
They won't do the same thing.
And if somebody's saying that one over the other
has a lot less side effects than I would care for it.
If you do a Syrex array test for food allergies,
are there results forever?
Or can your food allergies change?
So I think I answered that, but I answered again.
No, they're not forever.
Your food allergies can change.
So when you do a Syrex can, let's say,
some can change for the better,
meaning they will go back into normal range,
and then you'll have, and that would be all great.
But that's not just always the case,
because when you change your diet, you, okay,
you eat less of what was positive on that test.
Well, you have to eat more of something else.
And the truth is, is not even if you don't eat
more of something else, it's because you have,
at the image gut, that's why you have
the antibodies in the first place.
So it's gonna take time to heal that damage gut.
So I do not ever recommend running a Syrex 10,
more than like every six months,
because you gotta work out healing your gut.
So when you have a really bad test on that,
that's not like, oh, you're just sensitive
to all these foods you can't eat anything
for the rest of your life.
No, no, no, no, it's just telling you
that your gut is so damaged, you gotta heal your gut.
So I've had people that had irritable bowel syndrome
or Crohn's disease, and they test it.
I mean, like everything was, it was,
it wasn't like what you're sensitive to,
it's like, let's count the number of foods
that you can't eat.
So then they would try to eat those foods,
but if you're not healing the gut and call me
that I'll, call me the immune response style,
you're never gonna get this person better.
So remember, if you already have self-antibodies,
like in the case of Crohn's disease,
they have antibodies to GI tissue
that, so they have an autoimmune attack on their,
their epithelial cells, it's many different antibodies
to different GI tissues you can have.
And let's say it's the epithelial cells
that lie in the gut, and every time you cause
an inflammation in the gut, you're gonna cause,
you know, more destruction of self-tissue.
So you have to decrease that cause of inflammation.
So it's essential that these people do a Cyrex tend to know
one of the things that I really need to cut out
for a period of time while I'm trying to heal the gut.
When you're dealing with autoimmune disease,
if anybody has studied my course on that,
you'll find out you have to find the triggers.
And many times food is at least a trigger
that you have to call that down.
So that will change over time.
The more you could heal the gut,
the more that you could make permanent changes for the better.
Now some food is antibodies,
and antibodies to certain peptides have been proven
over the course of 20 years
that these tests have been available
that stick around longer.
And that one of those is gluten.
So, but, you know, I've seen gluten antibodies go back
to normal and I've seen people that have swored up and down
that they don't eat one speck of gluten
and they're looking all across reactants and such.
And they still have gluten antibodies five years
after their initial test.
So, but it seems like other ones seem
to dissipate quite quickly.
So, that's the good news.
Could you explain how you know you don't have H. Pylora?
You don't.
So, you could do whatever I explained
those three tests for H. Pylora.
You read a threat test.
You could do a blood test for H.
Pylora, you could do a stool sample test.
If all of those are negative, it still doesn't eat
you don't have H. Pylora.
So, you could have H. Pylora that's harboring
underneath your endothelial tissue
in the smooth muscles of your arteries.
And it's never going to show up on a blood test
and it's never going to show up on a stool sample test.
It's definitely not going to show up on a urea breath test.
So, well, how do you transfer that?
Well, unless we were going to go and do a biopsy
of that tissue, well, actually,
that's how they found that out.
So, it would actually study doing post-mortem biopsy.
So, people that died of heart disease,
they did post-mortem biopsies
of where the damaged vascular tissue was,
where the occlusions were.
And they found Raleia burgodorphine,
which is also a grand negative bacteria,
H. Pylora, a grand negative bacteria, heavy metals
and a couple of other things to get rid of, to study now.
But those were there in the presence
of almost all of those patients.
So, H. Pylora is a big player.
Grand negative bacteria are big players
because grand negative bacteria have label polysaccharides
in their cell membrane, which make them even worse bacteria.
So, because when you do kill them,
they'll liberate label polysaccharides,
which are larger enough to create an immune response,
which can be deadly, who's dependent on where it is.
So, it's best to just treat yourself for H. Pylora
on a regular basis, honestly.
Well, how would I do that?
Well, it's using things like that are in our pair of clear
apex makes it H. Pylora specific for that.
There's a number of different companies
that make things to kill H. Pylora.
Burberry is one of the best things to kill H. Pylora.
Boralic is really good to kill H. Pylora.
This thing's actually working really well.
It worked better than antibiotics.
It had no side effects except if you're out of blood,
that are you can't be taking polymeric.
Or should I just go through a protocol for sure
and I understand it's hard to test for it?
Is that correct?
I saw Dr. Jen say in her Facebook group the other day
that people with active cancer should it take glutathiled
or anoceros cystic, both in which I muscle tested for
it had been taking before and after my surgeries.
Why would she think that she didn't qualify
and say during chemo, which I've heard from conventional docs?
So I think we've covered this a lot of times
and I cover this in my book, but I'm going to go over it again.
Glutathione, what is glutathione do?
Glutathione is your main into a cellular anti-opsivite.
What's anocetal cystic?
Anocetal cystic is simply a precursor for glutathione.
Glutathione is recycled in the cell.
Glutathione is present in the weight of code.
Glutathione is present in the cell cytoplasm.
Glutathione is made cellular anti-oxid.
What's at the, when you have oxidizing agents come in the cell,
this dispersion stuff, it gets rid of them
and reduces them so that they're not this dangerous
oxidizing agent, because an oxidizing agent
can be damaging to a cell.
So oxidizing agents are toxins, okay, poisons.
Oxidizing agents can cause cancer.
Oxidizing agents can reduce, can oxidize further
to peroxidite trait, which can be very damaging to cells.
It can damage cell membranes, can damage makeup,
condria, can damage the nucleus, can be a cause of cancer.
Well, then why wouldn't we want everybody to take
a bunch of antioxidants?
Oh, so why wouldn't we?
Well, because cancer cells are already rapidly replicating,
and they're rapidly replicating a far inferior quality cell.
And one of the inferior qualities of a cancer cell
is that it has incomplete mitochondria.
So a cancer cell has incomplete mitochondria.
Cancer cells don't have good, good thiode production.
And a cancer cell that is more susceptible to oxidation
and death by oxidizing agents.
That's why chemotherapy,
when you give chemotherapy to a cancer patient,
it can kill the cancer.
Well, chemotherapy makes, can kill healthy cells too.
Yes, because chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent.
And chemotherapy can be a cause of cancer.
Well, then why would I take it?
Cancer cells don't produce as much glutathione
and cancer cells are more susceptible to oxidation
and death by oxidation than healthy cells.
So one theory is that if you give a cancer patient
glutathione or an acetylcystine,
you could actually be helping their cancer stay alive
because you're helping the cancer survive an oxidative process.
So I wrote about that in my book,
12 years ago, and I first published it,
15 years ago, or whatever.
I still hold fast to that,
unless what I test a person with muscle testing
that it tests that they need it.
So I know there's alternative doctors that go,
no, everybody should be out glutathione and acetylcystine,
but I'm not talking about that.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm just not talking about that.
I just don't agree with what you said.
Everybody should be on something period.
Of course, there's some things that are,
you know, everybody should be as much sugar
and everybody, you know, cancer patients should watch
but they shouldn't be taking glutamine nutrients.
But some cancer patients do well with glutathione and acetylcystine.
So, only a small percentage of my patients are doing any glutathione, just so you don't.
So I agree with Dr. Jen to a point.
So I agree with the general statement, but everybody's unique also.
So also just that side note on glutathione and NLCs and cystine for those who don't have cancer
should everybody be taking glutathione and intestinal cystine.
You could argue that it is good because we're exposed to such a high quantity of oxidizing agents.
However, you have to remember that the oxidation process in your body happens naturally.
You are naturally creating reactive oxygen species within the cell.
It has a purpose.
Remember, nothing is all good or all bad when you talk about physiology.
You have to have a balance of good oxidation and good antioxidation taking place all the time.
What's the purpose of your body?
Create reactive oxygen species.
There it is.
Poisons, your body's creating these reactive oxygen species for a purpose.
That's how you kill pathogens.
So another way you kill pathogens is through the creation of reactive oxygen species.
So that's how you can kill intracellular pathogens.
So you have to remember you have to have a balance of opinions.
I would agree that we are exposed to poisons on a daily basis that our ancestors were never exposed to.
So supporting the recycling of glutathione can be helpful.
So, but with cancer, you have to be more careful how much you do support.
Next question.
I seem to have an issue with nail fungus.
I believe it's systemic.
I believe you suggested soaking by nails in something, but also are there some herbs, etc.
I can take.
What else can I do?
I have had issues for years.
It's getting a little worse the last five weeks.
We have a product called Funga Clear.
Funga Clear.
That you could use from a systemic standpoint.
That's not going to deal with the nails.
Your blood glow to your nails is so incremental that taking something orally is not going to deal with that.
You've got to go with that herbal foot soak.
We don't sell that in the store, but you can look that up on Amazon.
What silk.
I think just search out on Amazon herbal antifungal foot soak.
And it's just a blend of herbs that you mix up, but you soak your feet in there.
We've had really good results with it.
I have had my botoxin tested and was very high in aquatoxin.
I did your recommendation binder for a month or so until it ran out, but not tested since again.
So you're ever.
Different types of fungal.
They came mold in your body.
You can have active fungal infection.
That's different than my go toxins.
So you can have a my go toxic issue.
So my go toxins are toxins that bold produces.
And it can be airborne mold.
Most commonly, it's going to be building black mold from buildings.
Of course, you can get it from foods to nuts and different things like that.
Even coffee can have toxins in them and they elicit my go toxins.
And then you can eat them and your absorbing my go toxins.
My go toxins are not living organisms.
My go toxins are toxins from my go from mold.
So those are poisons.
Those are going to be poisonous to anyone.
Living fungal reactions are different.
So that's it.
That's a infestation of a pathogen.
So you want to elicit an immune response and use urbels that will directly kill them.
Hence you use our fungal clear.
If you have my go toxins, you'd use a key later or a binder to pull those out.
Those are chemical toxins that you're pulling out and it can take years to pull those out, especially if you have courage exposure.
So you have to stay on clear talks for a while or whatever you put you on.
Living fungal infection is different.
You're not going to use a key later to pull that out.
So that's a pathogen that you have to kill.
So you have to do things to stimulate your immune system.
It's in your feet.
Then you have to also try to kill it directly there.
And there's a whole bunch of other techniques.
I'm killing it using Mr. Rita and your feet using it.
H2O2 hydrogen peroxide on your feet doing a whole bunch of different techniques that you can search the web on.
Soking your feet in different things that can be helpful.
Running the fungal programs on the right can be helpful as well.
And then there's a third which you don't actually hear.
But since I'm talking to one of my people talk about it, there's a third type of reaction to molds and fungi.
And that's what's called an IGE reaction.
So an IGE reaction is a is more of a sensitivity reaction.
So those are the people that like walk into a building.
They're like, oh my gosh, I can't stay in this building.
I got a headache instantly.
What's the matter?
Oh my gosh, it's mold.
There's mold in the building.
Everybody else is like, what are you talking about?
I don't spell any mold in this building.
Those people are not crazy.
That is they have.
They can have IGE antibodies and you can test for it.
If you want, but those people don't really need to be tested for it.
They know they haven't.
They cannot tolerate any mold.
And so because of past exposure, they developed IGE antibodies.
Sometimes they'll just never dissipate.
And they're always going to be hypersensitive to mold.
They just need to get out of the area because they literally could have an antiflactic reaction
if they stay in an environment like that.
So three different things.
Take care of it differently.
Are infrared or near infrared.
Sauna is good for cancer.
Yes, yes, they are.
And it's take a step back.
So the infrared and dear infrared.
Sauna's.
Really are just sources of heat.
So a true infrared unit.
We'll not show any color as it's below the red spectre.
So honestly, a true infrared unit.
That's, you know, that's producing infrared.
Is about it that like our infrared.
Hyperthermia unit is only like six inches by five inches.
And those things are like five grain.
Okay.
So you think that you're getting true infrared.
I don't care what their brochure says.
From the panel that heats up.
No, you are not.
Plus true infrared heats deep in the tissue.
It doesn't really have surface heat.
So a true infrared or an infrared sauna or near infrared sauna.
Right.
Honestly, you're not really getting any of the benefits.
No matter what the company says.
From infrared.
Radiation.
That's just out there.
So just cross at them.
So let's just say.
Sauna.
Sauna's good for cancer.
The answer is yes.
And the reason is is because you're.
You're sweating.
And when you're sweating, you're helping detoxify through your skin.
And you're taking pressure off your liver and your kidneys.
That's why it's good.
We really want infrared.
You have to get a hyperthermia unit.
It has to be skin to skin contact.
It has to be about six inches away from your skin.
And it's only going to treat a very small area at one time.
My potassium is low.
2.6.
Is this from diarrhea?
I assume.
Yes, I probably say that's exactly right.
But could this be part of my kidney issues, fluid retention?
It could be.
I'd have to look at all your labs.
And you'd have to schedule a time that we could do that.
That actually takes time to look at everything.
I really can't do that.
I'm going to call it this.
I haven't taken Tylenol every four hours to tablets for the past year.
Is there a danger to continue this?
Yeah, there is.
Tylenol can be very dangerous to multiple metabolic pathways in the liver.
Realistically, there's like statistically by their own statistics.
There's there's about 15,000 people a year that die from Tylenol toxicity.
And it's shuts down their liver and they die of liver failure.
I'm not trying to scare you.
And what are you going to do for pain?
I mean, what are you going to do?
If you can find other ways to deal with it, you would be better.
Even if you have an ability to cut that out, you know, cut it way down.
I would certainly be doing Castro packs over your liver.
I'd certainly be considering doing coffee animals to help your liver.
You want to keep your liver aligned.
Okay, so really super important.
One of the things you can do for pain other than Tylenol.
That's that is a struggle that I feel your pain because there's not a whole lot of natural solutions for it.
CBD can be beneficial for some people.
THC, which is the psychoactive form of marijuana has this problem with your best bet.
It's legal and just about every state.
You can get it in liquid form, cat tablet form, gummy form.
That can be extremely beneficial.
It does make you loopy.
Maybe that at least can get you through the night.
You have to only take Tylenol during the day.
Maybe you'd be cutting way down.
Take a high dose of THC at night.
It will certainly help you sleep.
And it will probably help you with the pain.
And it can help kill cancer.
So look at THC.
Just about every state has dispensaries for that.
You could buy it online if your state doesn't have dispensaries for that.
Start at a lower milligram dose like 2.5 to 5 milligrams.
And slowly work up.
It is to your pain relief.
Know that the side effects can make you feel loopy.
It's going to make you feel drowsy.
You're going to feel a little shy.
I hate the way it makes me feel.
I've never smoked marijuana or taken drugs in my life.
So I mean, I would do that versus having to take Tylenol
in a regular race.
I would try to do some other things.
In listening to low carb keto diets to reduce sugar,
it seems that is only half the protocol.
You have to cut the glutamine and other energy sources or cancer cells.
These usually are drugs that are prescribed.
So without a doctor prescribing drug.
If you can find one.
What else works to lower glutamine levels?
So really with glutamine.
So if you're trying to there are some drugs on the market to lower glutamine.
But they're they're hard to get a hold of now.
I forgot the name of that one.
What was it?
Get out.
I forgot the name of it.
Because I obviously can't prescribe it.
But it was hard to find somebody to use it.
Because you're using it basically off label.
So I don't even know.
I've had several people say that they can't get it.
The doctor was trying to prescribe it.
They can't get any place.
They can't play a place to get it.
So, but.
So it has been shown to drastically reduce glutamine and some patients that can be helpful.
Especially in patients with astrocytoma can be fed.
Astrocytomas which type of brain cancer can be fed directly by glutamine.
Remember your body will make glutamine.
It will break down glutamine from glutamates as well.
Remember glutamine is a precursor to glutamate.
It converts to glutamate, which is a neurotransmitter in your brain.
You need glutamate.
So it's not a matter of not having any glutamine.
So the big thing is you're just watching your glutamine in your diet.
The problem is if you're eating meat, you're eating glutamine.
There's glutamine in all meat products.
And there's negatives to not eating any animal protein.
So it's really tough.
You've got to find out what's going to work for you.
Many times it's that rotational diet where you're going to go on a diet that is eating meat, animal products, and glutamine for a period of time.
And you're going to rotate it off and you're going to be eating very little of it.
So yeah, if you're not going to, it's hard to reduce glutamine down to zero or or or dear zero.
It's very difficult to do.
I'm not taking antibiotics for the more organella.
I'm just taking probiotics and enzymes.
Okay.
Last time we talked to it.
Antibiotics.
How much burberry did garlic should I take for the more?
Well, you're going to have to take at least a gram or two of burberry.
And as long as you don't have blood-denied issues, you really can't overdose other garlic.
So if you're trying to kill a bacteria, taking high dose of burberry to garlic for.
Just dosing up on it can be very beneficial.
It's just if you, if you, the only issue with garlic is if you have it also or something like that that could be very irritated.
Also, so just watch that.
So taking high dose of garlic causes pain.
It's quite possible that you're going to also burberry typically won't irritate it all sort of garlic certainly does.
Should I start doing foot baths again?
If yes, how often?
Um, you can't, I would maybe just go back to once or twice a week.
Just do you know, that would be good.
Is there any benefit to rotating adaptogens or overlap?
Then is there a way to tell which ones are the best for me?
Well, the best way to tell what adaptogens are best for you is how it makes you feel.
It's a work for you because it feel like it balances your mood.
Is it, you know, you're taking adaptogens to balance your formal.
So you're not taking adaptogens to reduce.
Like estrogen and progesterone that you can't know if it's reduced unless you measured it.
So you're taking adaptogens to balance your pituitary, your thyroid, your adrenal hormones.
And you're going to, I mean, a person's taking adaptogens because they're tired or they're, you know, they have anxiety or they have fatigue or, you know, you should go to symptoms.
So if you're taking adaptogens and you're not noticing any symptoms, yes, you should rotate adaptogens and see how those symptoms change.
If you go, well, I don't have any of those symptoms. I'm just taking them.
Well, then maybe you don't don't, don't ask the drug. Thank you.
Maybe you don't need to take adaptogens.
Don is the glue to be drunk. Thank you, Mark.
If you don't find somebody who does, um,
uh,
uh, prescribe that if you could even that would be helpful for other people.
All right, I have to call it a night. Thanks for being on today.
A lot of questions came in, uh, like that.
I don't like it when we're just don't.
All right, God bless. I'll talk to you guys next week.
Bye bye.